hi everyone it's joanna here guess who's
back with me again it's wendy so today
we'll be doing a really fun step workout
where you'll be burning lots of calories
i will be leading the first part of the
workout which will focus on cardio lots
of fat burn as well as agility that's
right and i will be leading the second
half of the workout where i'll be
focusing more on strength endurance okay
so if you have a step board grab your
step bot if you don't have a step bot
don't worry you can't do this workout
without a stat bot and this workout will
be according to music yes so let's do
this and let's just have fun
[Music]
hey hey we are going to start our
warm-up so just listen up if you have a
step board use one remember the a b c a
abs brace be back tall and see correct
foot placement yeah make sure the whole
shoe goes up on the board all the time
and stay close to the board are we ready
let's go
march on the spot so moving the arms
nice and strong remember abc yeah abs
tight back nice and tall and correct
foot placement hey stay close to the
board we're going into a step touch like
this
step touch
good let's move the arms
i want to get you nice and warm to get
you ready for the workout
good job
nice and easy
four marches on the board four three two
one
up again four three two one come on show
me at strong march
when you come down make sure you stay
close to the board
last one here
basic step right left go up and down
keep the arms moving
good strong much guys
let's go
keep breathing this is just a warm up
and if you want a little bit more check
this out a little jog up and down
very good
move the arms
two more
last one back to your step touch
right and left
good how about some arms
out and in
open through the chest keep the elbows
low
nice
ready to march on the board starting
with the left foot four marches up four
three two one come on down stay close to
the board especially when you come down
yeah
correct foot placement the whole shoe
goes up on the board
last one
basic step left right left right keep
the arms moving
good
nice powerful march
up and down
want a little bit more here we go a
little jog up
and down
arms
good
if you feel a little dancing
maybe
two more
last one we've got a knee and tap down
one knee one tap one knee and tap good
stay close to the board
i know you're gonna hear me say this a
lot but that's for safety yeah so they
can go up and down nice and easy three
knees repeater three
two
one tap down
three
two
one and tap take a look at this leg keep
it nice and soft lots of knee bend tap
and up
other side step knees tap down
go up
brace your car abs tight
good job guys
arms moving
knee and tap
one more
three knee repeater three
two tap down
keep that knee bent
stay low in the legs abs tight
two more of this
last one
are you ready to pose ready to pose
feeling strong
next one we're gonna go a little bit of
mambo a little bit of dance step so you
might need to step over here take a look
at this one we're gonna go up down
forward
up
and back yeah up
and forward and up we call this mumbo
number five
ready so it goes up
and forward and practice this with me
last one
then we got the shuffle it goes single
single hold single single hold okay we
need to keep our energy for the workout
all right
we're gonna start with the foot on the
board just like this
chest up nice and tall and
ready to mumbo rock it baby
go there goes up
and forward
up and back remember we practiced this
earlier
up and back
and two entry and four
nice last one
ready to shuffle go single single hold
single single freeze one and two
one and two and pop
one two boom straight up pose
just like that
march on the spot
across the top
go up
and down
up
yeah if you don't have a step four
that's perfectly fine just follow you
and uh
stay on the floor
good
whoa stay here stay here
foot on the board
up forward up and back mambo number five
move the arms
a little dancy yes i know
last one
shuffle
single single double
hold
one two and freeze
one and two and hold one and two and
freeze
nice make sure you're in the balls of
your feet heels off the floor wait
forward
march march march
across the top
nice
and
use your arms if you want a bit more
work yeah
whoo are we breathing
we should be breathing
last one
hey come behind the bars just like this
check this move out we've got front
side
back knee run
front
side
back knee
good down
pasta ready one two three knee five six
seven eight one two three four five six
seven eight
oh run run i want to see fast feet
one more
ready to switch other side left leg
sorry for the sounds i made
one more
you know what
right and left alternate oh my goodness
[Music]
keep moving
if you're tired stay on the low option
you don't have to
jump i know i'm cheating
go
feel the beat down
oh my goodness
oh
we're almost there i promise you
freeze
oh
oh my gosh that was tiring and
the next one
we're gonna alternate
upper body and lower body yeah so i need
you to turn your bod this way
yep
just check to make sure the board
turn this way for the next exercise so
we're going to work on lower body first
we're going to go into a squat like this
make sure sit back sit low imagine
there's a chair behind you and we're
gonna come up
that's your option
okay
yes and you know what we're gonna go
into
mountain climbers and burpees
yay
okay
so feet wide but stay close to the board
yeah so it's much easier to jump up or
move up and down okay always remember
that sit back everyone imagine there's a
chair behind you
nice little chair that's gonna work your
legs and your butt come up like this
yeah
chair where's the chair
it's all the way back
push your bum back
towards that chair
and sit really low one
two
drop squat so this is called a drop
squat yeah
okay
we could do this the whole day
no we're not
and down a little faster one two
one two drop
one two hold remember that move earlier
single single double single single hold
one and two and drop
nice if this is too easy
sit back yeah that's to protect your
knees
and work your thighs and butt
good job
how about formal
up
and the tree stay close to the board
sit back it's a very low chair
last one
i'm sure you're happy to hear that
okay now
we're gonna work upper body and arms
and your core
you're ready we're gonna go
into your plank so everyone just check
to make sure
shoulder elbow wrist stacked
abs tight
mountain climber
and back nice and slow so as the knee
comes in crunch into the belly
exhale here
inhale here
breathe out
can we go a little faster in
in
now keep your bum low
and try not to move the upper body
shoulders are always stacked over your
elbows and wrists
you ready
faster now go only if you want to yay
oh okay breathing
i feel it in my arms
oh core
legs
eight more let's go
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two stain plank and hold check this move
out
an easy burpee goes like this the leg
closest to us
stand up hands on the board
step back one foot at a time
and i want you to stay in this option
if you're tired okay
just hold and stay in this option
good job a little faster just a little
one
two
up
down
one two and hold isometric go one
two
reach touchdown step back step back
raise your core
and up
down
back
back
stay and hold one more
and we're going to go faster only if you
want to otherwise stay with joanna yeah
go
up
touch
hold
one
two
you don't have to jump
one
two
touch and back
one
two
how about one more
oh
all right come on up everybody
okay
are we breathing yes we are okay just
feet wide close to the board just like
this and hold
nice
well done
come on up
okay listen up guys we are gonna work on
agility yeah we're gonna fat burn so
lots of movement coming up
please stay close to the ball all the
time yeah so we're gonna go knee like
this careful when you switch change it's
a up down
okay and knee
with the arms is a bit more work
otherwise you can do this one
yeah
and then from here we're gonna go three
two
one and switch
got it we've got skiing oh my gosh
all right check this out okay listen i
need one foot on the ball like this
stay close to the board good job i'm
gonna lift that knee up
seven times
six
five
four
three
two
one switch change
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one and change
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one
switch change
raise your core lift those knees
three knees repeater
three
two
one
switch
three
two
one and switch
three
two are you counting
two
one
if it's too much just move your arms
like this yeah
three
two
one
told ya
cardio work
three
two
one take a look hamstring curl kick your
butt
so heel up to the butt just like this
yeah
you want a bit more work martial arts
punch it out boom
boom retract go out in out in
take a look at this one down
stay close to the ball guys
four more four
three
two
one stay here hold
nice come on over
march
catch your breath here take a nice deep
breath in with me
exhale are you ready for round two
yes let's do this
seven knees go seven six
five
four
three
two one switch change seven
six
brace your core
three
two
one
switch change
come on keep moving
five
four
three two
one
five
six
seven
eight three knees
three
two
one switch
three
two
one
nice
hamstring curl ready straight into it
punch
it helps if you smile when you do this
check this out
skiing skiing sit back
and as if this is not enough let's make
it look more like skiing
stay with me you're almost there guys
last one hold stop
god nice work guys
so
joanna was take you take us through the
second half of the exercise we're gonna
work on string you ready girl yes i am
well done wendy so i know all of you are
out of breath right now so wipe your
sweat drink some water take a short
break and we'll see you back
[Music]
all right guys welcome back to the
second block of this workout okay for my
part i will be focusing on strength
endurance and i know you've done lots of
crazy movements don't worry it's not
going to be crazy
i'm the crazy one that's right so for my
block
it's going to be one exercise per track
but we will be playing with different
tempos okay if you have a sub bot use
your stat bot if you don't have a step
bot then just follow wendy so for the
first track is going to be squats
if you have a step bot step right in
between your step bot okay and remember
with squats always point your knees
forward and push your butt back keeping
your body up right all right are we
ready step slightly wide let's go
okay so toes pointed slightly out
and now remember to always push your
butt back okay so i just want you to get
this movement to begin with
chest up push your butt back
and come back up all right
nice and easy
now let's go three counts down
up
one
two
three and ah there you go one
two
three and up so slow
up one
two
up good job keep it smooth
again
nice and controlled movement
we're not rushing through this workout
so we're really working your lower body
okay good
ah let's go singles
up so bring the pace up
remember we're playing with tempo down
up
down
up
pushing through your heels
feel more
push
feel the burn on your thighs and your
glutes
up
good
and last few more
good okay
now place one
leg onto the board and one foot down
remember to keep it parallel okay so do
not place it forward place it
in the same line and now same thing
we're going to do the squat focusing on
our right leg right leg
one
down
and up there you go simple and nice are
we ready let's go
down
up
down
up good
nice and easy
so you should feel the work
on your right side
last one more and we're going to switch
to the left side
ready
down
good
keeping to the tempo
down
up
down
and now guess what we're going to go for
double
pulse
there you go
hop
hop double pulse
for a regressed version
follow wendy okay
hop
few more
keep going
oh it's burning i know
only squats
playing with different tempo
[Music]
done
very well done okay
so that was the lower body track now
let's move to the upper body track where
we'll be working on push-ups okay so
place your step bot directly in front of
you alright so for this track it's only
going to be push up and tricep dips
simple movement but again playing with
different tempo all right so place your
palms onto the step bot and remember to
keep your chest
close to the step board as you go down
drive your chest
towards the chest board
chest a board and push it up okay
getting my words lost there
that's it
okay good
so slow down
and one count up
down
up
good control down
up nice
[Music]
slow
two three and up slow
two three and up remember keep your butt
down
body in one line
and guess what we're going for singles
up
good
really power
through your movement
good
let's add that explosive movement down
up
i promise you
it's going to be a short track
down
up
are we still there
last two more
oh
good job okay
now
just step in front of your step board
okay
come in front
and we're going to work on tricep dips
so place your pumps onto the step bar
all right
same thing three down
one up one two three
up
good
and remember to keep your butt
close to the board one
two three
up
few more
and we're going for singles one more
are we ready go down
up
good
down up
feel the burn on your triceps
gentle tap onto the floor don't rest
i know it's burning
that's one more
now let's go for three puzzles one
two three
up small pauses two
three
up
two
three
up one more
and now drop and hold drop
hold up
drop
hold and up good we're almost at the end
up 15 seconds left drop hold
up
now slow
down
up controlled
really small movement
but you can really feel it in your
triceps
up
one more
good job okay
i know my chest my arms on fire so shake
it out okay it's back to our lower body
track
for this one we will be doing lunges
again
simple exercise but let's get the
movement right okay so place
one leg onto the step bot
and the other foot lift the heels of
your foot okay so lunge down
step back
and switch the other side
okay so we'll be doing alternating
lunges are we ready let's go let's go
slow and easy
down
up
not rushing through the workout
really focusing on your form
and remember to keep your body
in a straight line
good
back
nice
control movement
and we're going to
follow the beat
one down up
back
forward down up and back four counts
wall three
two
one
good there you go
down up
forward down up
back one more
guess what three pulses one two three
switch
one two three and push power through
your front leg
good
nice
i know
it's burning
stay with me
whoo small pulses
one more
let's go for singles
switch
bring the speed up
but remember to launch low
switch
[Music]
break
okay so let's add in a little bit of
curtsy lunch okay so place your foot
diagonally on the step bot same thing
we'll start with regular lunges
and the next one what i want to do is
cross over
into curtsy okay
slow
cross
good
slow
cross
now let's change
slow
don't worry if i see my back
cross good
slow good
cross good are we ready
back to alternate lunges
left down up
back
so that was a short break for you okay
down up
three
step down up
we're getting into three pulses
one
two three and switch
one
two three and switch good
stomp your foot down
keep going
keep into these beats
my quads
they're on fire
okay
a little bit of variation drop hold up
drop
hold and up good
drop
hold and up
drop hold and up
done
okay
oh just like this
three tracks are done and the final
track will be focusing on your core okay
for this track we will be working on
plank and crunches so again simple
movements with different varieties so
let's get down onto the floor if you
have a step bot place both palms onto
the step bot and drive both
legs up
remember that you should be looking
directly towards the step bot
and keeping your back flat so this is a
solid plank position okay
all right so the first move is going to
be spider-man blank plank
slow and easy
no rush
start off slow
[Music]
[Music]
keep going
[Music]
one more
and
we want to switch to shoulder tap
good shoulder tap
remember
back flat do not shift your hips
good
tap and down
tap and down
now
inhale jacks
[Music]
look at my foot
and we want to bring this speed up okay
good
keep going
few more
and now
let's get into playing jacks
good
it's burning
[Music]
only 20 seconds guys
good drop it down now let's slide down
onto the ground
let's get into crunches okay
place your foot onto the step board
okay keep your knees bent
are we ready hands by your head
slow crunches
slow
down
we're not rushing
up and down
just lifting your shoulders off the
floor
small crunches
one
two
three and down
three pulses
and down
one
two
three and down good crunch it up
for your upper abs working
one
two
three and up
one
two
three
down
last few more
last one
okay
all right drive your knees in
back
in
or towards the end last one more
in
and down
ah
all right push yourself back up
really well done
okay that is the end of our workout
now let's
work on a short cooldown okay so
what i want to do is just
sit on the stat bot all right
let's just stretch it out sit on the
step bot or onto the floor
and if you can
try to just
reach the opposite toe and feel the
stretch along your hamstrings
okay
if you're on the floor that's absolutely
fine
good
and now change the other side
point your leg forward
reach
good
all right and let's just twist our body
so same thing
cross over and just twist
nice
look as far back as you can
and change the other side
and just twist
and shake it out
okay now let's come up
let's get into standing
few stretches for the upper body
cross your shoulder
good job
and back
into tricep stretch
point it back
all right and change
the other side
tricep
[Music]
good job
okay i'm just gonna move the step by the
side
and just feel
um circles okay forward
just really release all the tension
we've done so much work
back both on our cardio as well as
strength
and shake it out
okay
very very well done
amazing job guys i hope you really
enjoyed this step workout that wendy and
i put together
don't worry if you can't synchronize to
begin with keep doing this workout keep
practicing the moves and eventually
you'll be an expert okay it gets better
every time yes it gets better every time
and if you do want more workout videos
from myself and wendy then do let us
know in the comments below and let us
know which part of the workout did you
enjoy the most and don't forget to also
like this video hit the subscribe button
if you haven't yet done it and i will
see you we will see you in the next
workout bye see you guys
[Music]
you